what is happening there reject nation
looks like it's shaping up to be a new
rock stars weekend here at the real
rejects we're gonna watch today doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
post credit scenes and ending explained
this is very necessary for us because
i'm not gonna lie
wasn't sure who that was
still don't know so i'm very curious to
hear what eric voss has to say guys
we're gonna be doing our live stream
with uh koi gendro this coming sunday
looking around the 11 30 a.m 12 p.m
pacific standard time but yeah i mean
sitting right in front of eric voss he
was literally like inches behind me and
just
no padding it up it was half time to
turn around and be like what you got
but then i thought he would be really
annoyed at me for doing that so i didn't
do it anyway let's do this
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and this is an explanation of the
ending and post credit scenes for doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness a
film that shocks us with what exactly
directed by sam raimi means that's like
we saw with wanda when your dreams are
finally within reach they are ripped to
shreds the spoilers morning in case me
saying i'm discussing the indian post
credits since this movie wasn't clear
enough because it will be spoiling the
entire multiverse of madness plot in
this video so if you haven't seen the
film and you need me to tell you this go
watch this movie on the biggest screen
you can it is amazing to look at i will
stay here waiting for you so dr strange
madness has two post-credits scenes but
it's really the madness that comes
before throughout this movie that we
need to break down first yeah so in this
movie one of max moff seeking a universe
with billy and tommy hunts down america
chavez for her ability to travel the
multiverse in the opening scene leading
to the death of defender strange doctor
strange reaches out to her for help in
doing so letting her know exactly where
america chavez is and so she sacks
kamertage and strange in america escape
to earth 838 an advanced utopian reality
where they meet mortar supreme and the
rest of the illuminati marvel's
illuminati in the comics is a six-member
group of leaders like the u.n world
security council in this case for
superheroes seeking to best defend earth
in the mcu the lineup is murder supreme
replacing supreme strange and this
dimension died a hero defeating thanos
we think but also captain carter this
universe's first avenger hillary well
returning is peggy carter playing a
live-action version of her what if
character wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute are we a hundred percent
sure that that is the same captain
carter from what if this could just be
another captain car from another
universe the part of me feels a little
bit let down if you're like captain
carter what if we're building her up and
then
she she does
and especially too because they don't
really make any illusions to what if so
it really feels like it could just be
another variant because i actually like
the illuminati death scene but at the
same time if that is the same one not
sure how i feel about that especially
after all the hype they made about like
oh what if's gonna factor in if it's
just in that way i feel like that's a
bit of a cop-out maria rambo captain
marvel defender of the cosmos lashanna
lynch that's tom cruise iron man well
presumably a captain marvel were in this
universe she was irradiated by the light
speed engine instead of carol danvers
then black bolt leader of the inhumans
the keeper of the terrigen mist justice
for inheritance in his role from abc's
canceled inhuman series reed richards
aka mr fantastic fantastic board with
john
krasinski actually playing the role
we've all been fantastic for years head
of the baxter foundation where christine
palmer works alongside ultra on
centuries i'm excited to be watching
this for the second time tonight but i'm
really excited to be watching this for
the third time next week what john
krasinski showed up on screen whatever
lines he had couldn't hear a damn thing
he said
cheers
losing their [ __ ] and i know it's going
to be the same thing tonight i really
wonder what those lines of dialogue
until home video you won't find out and
then of course this illuminati's founder
charles xavier professor x leader of the
mutants patrick stewart returning for
the fox x-men franchise but here in his
olive green suit yellow hoverboard big
ass chairs
destroying universes in an incursion
forcing black bolts to destroy him with
the whispered i'm sorry since of course
black bolt's voice can level mountains
and this illuminati lied enshrining
strange as a hero meanwhile wanda uses
the dark hole to dreamwalk aka possess
the bodies of one of her variant selves
from another universe and wrecks the
illuminati sealing black bolt's mouth
leo style so he obliterates his own
brain
body like ribbon severing captain carter
at the midsection with her own shield
crushing captain marvel under rubble and
then professor x tries to rescue wanda
inside her mind but the scarlet witch
snaps his neck why
so strange
she's like the terminator man into a
post-incursion universe where strange
meets a sinister strange third eye opens
on his forehead a twisted evil
manifestation showing how this guy's
soul has been corrupted by the darkhold
the two strangest duel with music and
strange such a great stream such a
creative hailing him on a fence below
yet the third eye opens because the soul
of the damned remains alive so then
strange uses this universe's dark hole
to dreamwalk into that corpse of
defender strange over to the temple on
wounded war mountain to confront wanda
and save america in doing so he exposes
his own soul to the souls of the damned
and eventually manages to harness these
souls into a replacement cloak it is
sick america punches wanda back into
west view making billy and tommy see her
as a monster i voted plot leaks i was
reading one that came out a few months
ago that was so accurate to the actual
movie but there were some minor
differences in there i interpreted as
this must have been the original edit
because i believe the original it was
like 2 hours and 40 minutes and then
re-shot it trimmed it down and blah blah
blah and that original plot leaked yeah
all that happened and america chavez and
wanda got into like a much bigger fight
that led into more multi-verses as i've
heard a lot of people complain about how
we didn't go to enough multiverses
didn't really bother me but i understand
the the gripe that some people had i
wonder if this this could be the first
time you get like an extended cut give
us the extended cut it was a raby cut
i'm sure he would want one too arawanda
finally realizing her mistakes implodes
the temple and destroys the darkholds in
every reality america is left a sorcerer
in training at camertaj and strange
takes a morning stroll but then suddenly
a third eye opens on his forehead and he
screams this leads to a post-credits
scene where strange is greeted by the
sorceress clea played by charlize their
own who tells him that he created an
incursion and they need to fix it okay
opens a rift to the dark dimension and
strange who now proudly opens that third
eye joins her unafraid now the comics
clea is the sorcerer's supreme of the
dark dimension niece to uncle dormammu
who becomes a major partner to strange
and eventually his spouse it was only a
matter of time before he joined the mcu
and her and this movie's repeated use of
the word incursion is super important as
it points to a possible secret wards
crossover event oh cool ah
that makes a lot more sense
i'm not gonna lie when she showed up i
went oh
it's [ __ ] charlie's third she's here
charlize will save the day who is that
who she played exactly are they friendly
are they in love what's going on i
couldn't i didn't pick up on the vibe
bit of a weird transition because the
movie ends with this like horrific
medicine ah i bursted the third eye
and then the very next scene he's like a
hug up third eye i mastered it
kick ass actually that complements a lot
better now especially with the romantic
angle of doctor strange and christine
palmers of how like they love each other
but they can't be with one another cleo
for her to be introduced and if they do
go down the road where they fall in love
and they start up a romance that could
be something like really unique to witch
wizard witch so they said
sorcerers and also this leading to
secret wars i feel like that's what it's
really going to be multiverse madness
focus on madness and i think secret war
is going to be like the multiverse
all variants possible yeah in the secret
wars comics all the marvel heroes and
villains are respawned on a multiversal
plane called battle world in the more
recent 2015 version of the events it was
doctor doom who oversees this in the
original 80's storyline it was a
beyonder now there is a second postcard
scene with bruce campbell's cameo as
pizza papa papa john's style pizza ball
street vendor in the illuminati
dimension of earth 838 whom strange left
cursed so that his left fist kept
punching his own face an homage to sam
raimi and bruce campbell's
the evil death series and ash's infamous
cursed severed hand that attacks him
strange earlier said that the spell
would last three weeks and here we are
three weeks later his pizza balls melted
the spell wears off and he turns to
camera with the meta declaration of it's
over folks there is so much to do
from this film and we will in the days
ahead trust me but some quick takeaways
we gotta address here the illuminati of
this movie exists in marvel earth 838
and this movie finally identifies the
main mcu as earth 616 a designation
until now only hinted at like with the
label on the film strip of lucky's
timeline
and in spider-man far from home when the
imposter mysterio quentin beck claimed
he was from dimension 833 and then this
dimension was 616 which now makes it
pretty coincidental that quentin beck
and gooderman pick actual multiverse
numerical designation
okay either way this means that in the
mcu multiverse exists one universe at
least where mutants the fantastic four
the inhumans and the terrigen mist and
captain carter all co-exist and things
like mutants terrigen mist the negative
zone if they exist in one dimension they
can exist in others territory missed in
the comments famously how characters
like missing yeah yeah it's true it
seems like the mcu version of that is
gonna go in a different direction yet
still deregin myths exist in the mcu
folks mutants exist in the mcu x-men are
coming still not here but they're coming
and if all these things can exist in the
mcu hopefully so too can living versions
of some of these brutally murdered
members of the illuminati first off when
earth 616 popped up in theaters it was
so funny because it was like a packed
theater it just scattered were people
losing their [ __ ] and then everyone
going
what's the big deal i don't understand
what's what that means
three six one six how many earths are
there it's just the numbers
have no idea what like around the
theater people are losing their [ __ ] i
thought like the illuminati would kind
of be this like multiversal team but
they're all from the same earth in and
of itself so it seems like the real
mash-up or the rewriting would happen
the secret wars kind of did what you
know comparatively to dc what the
flashpoint did which is sort of like
keep sub and smash together some others
i feel like after secret wars is
probably when we'll get mutants and
they're planting the seeds to just sort
of slap it together i suppose i don't
know what was cut out of that 40 minutes
does that even try to explain you know
professor x and you're just another b
with powers which is the simplest way to
keep it for your first film maybe after
a secret wars type thing maybe they
would have a multiversal illuminati
basically that's like hey we're all kind
of assembled of different universes and
maybe we can meet in the middle to
oversee all this because yeah it did
feel a little more contained than i was
expecting in this movie but like you
said i think that's probably actually a
good call given like the murmur that
came up when people were like 616.
what's that lynch atwell wore those
suits with confidence my friends and
krasinski as reed richards notably
mentioned having a wife and children
referring to sue storm correctly
invisible woman and their child franklin
richards a key omega-level mutant in the
comics and implying a lineage of
descendants that will eventually lead to
nathaniel richards aka kang dakota
actually the recent news that john watts
has stepped down from directing the mcu
fantastic four movie has led many to
speculate that john krasinski could take
over as actor director as he's done an
amazing job with the two a quiet place
films and has previously expressed
interest now it remains to be seen if
krasinski will be the mcu's reed
richards in every universe or just this
one in a different actor will play the
character in the future as the mcu at
this point has shown that people would
get upset about that
either by the same actor or different
ones and that same uncertainty applies
to how the mcu will introduce the x-men
patrick stewart just seems like a fan
service return from a beloved era and
maybe less like a harbinger of other
past era x-men and mutants that kevin
feige will bring back and other than
ryan reynolds deadpool there seem to be
no other plans to bring back like hugh
jackman or james marsden or halle berry
as of yet the options remain open they
definitely cut out a bunch of cameos i
feel like really confident about that
there is a longer cut out there that is
enormously longer and i imagine that
that would be there's probably they
probably could have some characters and
wanted to reserve them for
some reason for the dvd yeah super cut
of all the cameos we didn't put in on
the three-eyed strange and clea so
strange's third eye likely indicates
that his soul remains cursed and bonded
with those souls of the damned and
whatever evil spirits surrounded the
darkhold despite the darkholds being
destroyed in every dimension whatever
evil lurks through them imbued into
those pages from the curses drafted by
c'thun remain living in doctor strange i
mean even after the climax of this movie
strange seemed to be in a bit of denial
about what lingering effects of his
embracing the souls of the damned would
mean for him going forward and the fact
that he's now at peace with this curse
suggests that he sees it as more of a
power the next stage of his evolution
him facing his fears so what awaits them
in the dark dimension well maybe an
incursion resulting in dr doom's battle
world and avengers 5 secret wars or
maybe the guy who famously loves
torturing the damned
or since kevin feige recently confirmed
loki and the removal of that kang
variant he who remains was the initial
cause of this madness and the hint of
reed richard's lineage the beneficiary
of these incursions might be kang the
conqueror again a lot to talk about
folks in my easter egg breakdown of this
film is coming to the channel tomorrow i
think followed by days weeks and months
ahead of us continuing to unpack this
day follow me on instagram and twitter
yeah for more analysis of everything
breakdown of madness
that breakdown is gonna be
batshit insane this movie's two hours of
information yeah yeah yeah
this would be the first new rock stars
it's longer than the actual movie so you
can't imagine how you're gonna do it
matt
uh yeah but take your time just make it
good anyway guys thank you so much for
being here keep a lookout for our live
stream this coming sunday and hey let's
do a picture
adelia chamberlain i would love to hop
through the multiverse to meet all the
different kinds of adelias see adelia
earth 616 is very much you know like a
liberal a little bit shy love the hell
out of her then i want to go to earth
838 where delia is like hardcore
republican bring earth 616 adelia over
to earth 838 and watch them deck it out
and then we go to another earth and
adelia there is a what john oh adelia
there is a box of french fries box of
french fries talking fries like that
adult swim chef absolutely powered aqua
teen adelia force and then when we go to
another wood what is she there she's a
black man that's right that touch that a
deal that joke john you know she's such
a
she's uh you know a an upstanding member
of society just like anybody else
well-played yeah
black adelia the best variant possible
the different planet uh you're uh oh
you're asian adelia
you're a bad guy
[Music]
you